um then it can affect you for example if
we remember magnus's lost to go cash he
was winning but maybe because he wasn't
feeling great he was rushing things took
his eye off the ball one blunder and
that was it turn around
so okay we expect Magnus to be slightly
more recovered and he starts with the
Sicilian Defense
or he opened with a much more
mainstream yeah more mainstream uh it's
very kind of you if I could say
provocative for magnus's previous
opening choices against aragaisy it was
just I don't know explain bad
I'm joking that they were bad but uh
they were basically saying to Eric I see
come and get me now he's saying to
everybody okay I know you're a good
player now uh I'm gonna play some of my
best openings and this is a variation we
call the taimanov Sicilian named after
Mark taimanov very strong Grandmaster
interesting that you mentioned bad
openings there's a story in Norwegian
news today on all the top Norwegian
newspapers that Magnus uh last week
played a tournament on chess.com opened
with basically the the worst possible
move on the board and his opponent a
player from Azerbaijan just resigned
because he was so offended yeah Ralph
mamadov very strong azerbaijani Grand
Master he just gave up after one move he
said okay he doesn't want to play chess
like this
it's a very emotional reaction it's kind
of understandable if someone did that
against me I would be like come on take
it seriously but
I mean it's not necessarily a handicap I
mean he's actually helping Mama Dove if
anything if Magnus is going to play a
bad move let him that gives you a
helping hand to beat Magnus maybe and
we've seen Magnus do it before so it's
nothing personal even against John
Christoph doodle right yeah Magnus it's
as if he's rolling a dice or something
sometimes he's just randomly choosing
moves and uh it's a psychological Ploy I
mean it's not breaking the laws of Chess
it's a valid move and if the opponent
gets flustered that's on them yeah so um
yeah that in uh in those games Magnus
was opening every white game with one G4
which is called the grob opening doesn't
sound good don't try it at home it
doesn't control the center we can see
your position and as black it was even
worse he was playing one G5 which is the
Borg which is like the opposite of the
grub
um but also just
very bad opening but he still won the
game then because his opponent just
resigned exactly and he was doing it
against everyone in that tournament so
it definitely wasn't anything personal
but uh I guess different players play
chess for different reasons uh Mama Dove
clearly
um wanted to play chess kind of on a
proper professional level Magnus wants
to play chess for fun and they're both
valid I think it's part of the chess
upbringing so to speak I mean the
further east you go the more kind of
principled and classical you are so if
you were to play something very unusual
and maybe even verging on the ridiculous
they would feel affronted because you're
not giving them the respect that uh you
deserve yeah meanwhile here in in the
west it tends to be a bit more
laissez-faire you know that everyone is
kind of just okay if you want to play a
bad opening play a bad opening against
me I'll enjoy getting that good position
but uh
it is what it is and uh meanwhile some
moves have appeared on the board yeah I
think we're just worse at openings here
in the west maybe that's it we just
don't study enough openings uh meanwhile
yeah it's a it's a rare branch of the
taimanov Sicilian so
um white has done some quirky stuff with
his Knights White's Knight has kicked
the black queen back to the eighth row
and uh maybe if we jump in we can show
some of the ideas uh because this is a
very standard position white has played
A variation we call the open Sicilian
throwing a pawn forward there has been a
trade of Pawns so there are some open
lines often uh it gets very crazy with
black keeping the king in the center
white often trying to attack that King
but uh first of all every guys who
played a move that I must admit I
haven't seen in years I've seen it
before but
um not on a clash between two Top Class
Grandmasters bringing the Knight moving
this night for the second time attacking
the black queen usually white for
example brings a bishop out or sometimes
uses the other night but uh after this
attack the black queen stepped back and
the bishop coming out
tell me if I'm wrong if I could but I
don't remember many clashes in this
hardly any clashes but it does seem to
be a specialty of Austrian Grandmaster
Valentin dragnev he's played this uh
four times with the white pieces with
the white piece isn't he one he's won
every single game I must say that one of
his opponents was like another fellow
Grandmaster but the rest of them were
perhaps they're not as strong
it's interesting to me because this
night looks misplaced uh this okay
meanwhile Eric I see castles but this
Knight looks like it can be kicked back
at any moment black can just push upon
kick it back
um actually this forces a trade of
knights because White's Knight is
required to defend its fellow here white
would first need to trade off this set
of knights and only then
step back and retreat but aragus is
arguing that this porn moves that black
has gained is not useful at All Black's
Queen is maybe misplaced on the back
Rank and white is ahead in development
having developed tonight bishop and
having castled already so uh I don't
know what you think Ivanka it's it's
interesting at least I Regice he's
clearly trying to surprise Magnus
normally the other way around yeah I was
gonna say he's using the world champions
weapons against him what we like to see
a bit of creativity
um yeah I think white is doing doing
okay I have no problems with the white
position I think it's building up to be
a very tense game we're going to see a
lot of the action develop in the middle
part yeah okay and I think Magnus needs
to hurry up and get on with the middle
part he needs to move his Bishop out the
way at some point and Castle the black
king before white gets too much activity
going
so yeah a very interesting start to this
game cool game all right it's
um
quarter finals you guys so remember best
out of four rapid games to decide each
of these quart final matches and if they
are tied after those four rapid games
then we head into tie breaks with the
first two Blitz Games and if they are
still tied it will be decided in
Armageddon who goes through to the
semifinals this is only the first rapid
game yeah it has exciting day I mean
it's going to be so frantic and so
thrilling I mean the action is going to
be Non-Stop and uh well talking about
non-stop action what the celebrator is
the first day of the quarterfinals well
first day of The Knockouts well we are
running a caption this competition and
there is a prize up for grabs one lucky
winner whoa have a chance to win this
air things view plus maybe pick up
it's green and we're asking you to
caption this picture it's a quite tough
one I think it comes up with something
funny but we have a Yankee stuffed Duda
there with his airplanes device and uh
yeah tweet us your answers what are you
captioning this yeah and as always you
can answer using the hashtag chess
Champs it's a tough one for you guys
today young crest of Duda did polls with
his earthings device that gave him a lot
of luck in the preliminaries he won the
whole preliminaries playing some
fantastic chess but what is a great
caption for this I was thinking
something with a UFO maybe I was
thinking of frisbee you know as well I
mean it does look
I I I'm really poor with these type of
things but uh David of course also you
know be creative do some painting in the
picture if you could Photoshop the
picture yeah yeah you could pointing out
something else I don't know
[Applause]
they're great though I have to say I'm
constantly impressed by the creativities
of our viewers yeah and meanwhile we
have seen the pawn step forward and
attack the Knight and we have seen a
Trader Knights and wow well well well I
wasn't expecting this porn recapture and
uh if we just jump in there's only been
one move but it's quite a critical
change of Pawn structure uh so we did
indeed see this Knight attacked the
night couldn't move uh first you have to
make this night safe and he decides the
trade it off and you're back You're
Expecting well we're always taught you
know you capture towards the center and
uh it's a very common pattern in this
particular Sicilian line that you you
capture that way and then as David
highlights you break in the center and
it becomes a tense standoff with the
bones and Magnus is just saying no
I'm gonna make my Pawn structure it's
almost symmetrical and drive your knight
back and he's accepting that he's maybe
slightly worse because of the light
squared Bishop that's trapped behind its
own pawns yeah this is definitely the
problem piece for black I guess magnus's
idea once the White Knight Retreats uh
Arjun now just choosing which Square
it's got a choice of two sensible
squares essentially but once he drops it
back for example this Square I think
magnus's idea is to block out the center
isn't this like waving a red flag for
white to accelerate the play and try to
blast open the center whilst the king is
in the center because if white can do
this then black is going to be in big
trouble yeah Magnus is King not ideally
placed I guess uh you mentioned this uh
in the Pasty ranker uh Magnus he says
it's fine if you're within two moves of
castling and here he can maybe gain some
time with the black bishop and check and
then run to safety but I agree it looks
very scary for black
here at the white pawns are very nice in
the center of the board but Eric I see
chooses a different Square he goes back
in a different direction uh in this
position he went back
to the center and now Magnus reacted not
with a pawn push because maybe now
White's Knight can Nestle in on this
nice F5 square if black wants to remove
it he might have to trade off a bishop
for it but uh instead Magnus brings his
Bishop up gaining time there's a battery
now against this H2 Pawn uh that would
come with a nasty check and Magnus is
just trying to gain time in order to
Castle next move
finally gearing up towards the end of
the opening uh better late than never to
Castle I Regice he drops his Knight back
and I'm expecting Magnus now either to
block up the center as we showed a
moment ago or
better late than never again get that
king castle it's moved that night a lot
and it's going to comment the same thing
I mean to my untrained eye I mean that's
an awful lot of moves with the night and
you know we're always taught in the
opening don't go wandering around with
one piece you know you've gotta be
harmonious with your forces yeah he's
moved it four times out of his first 11
moves that's just one night the other
night which got traded off he moved it
three times so out of his first 11 moves
uh seven moves were with white Knights
and one of them's gone so that's not
ideal strategy Black's Queen has moved a
couple of times though and Black's made
a lot of pawn moves as well now blocking
up the center Magnus
um so it's kind of swings and
roundabouts both sides have lost some
time but they are
kind of breaking some opening rules
and uh meanwhile Magnus at least has
good air quality I was a bit worried a
few moves ago kind of he put his head
down we could only see the top of his
hair that massive hair and uh yeah it
looked like he was kind of napping or
something but it looks like he's in good
conditions to play Yeah from what I can
see on the camera he does look a little
bit more healthy today I would say yeah
and he did go skiing yesterday so he
must be feeling better that's true uh he
looks at least like he's kind of curious
about this position and that's when
Magnus shines but this move
talking of curious Ivanka it's uh it's a
bit of a strange one he's asking all the
questions to Arjun he's saying hey you
know are you going to trade your Bishop
for the night uh just break up my Pawn
structure what are you gonna do I mean
I will probably just capture it I would
capture it as well and then I would try
to restrain that Paul Paul it's worth
yeah weaknesses long term and you want
to restrain it by bringing the White
Knight to the side one idea yeah and
that's I mean that's a nice move this is
actually an outpost normally we say
nights on the river dim
actually this season a lot of players
they've been avoiding making that
mistake putting their Knights on the
edge of the board we saw that mistake
made several times last season but now
the White Queen can come out attack this
weakness and the White Knight the reason
it's good here on the Outpost is because
it can actually re-centralize later to
the F5 Square maybe once you support it
to me it looks very nice magnus's idea
surely now is not to Castle on the king
side because here his king would be too
open uh if you look at the pawn
structure around it it's
too fractured the idea must be the other
way not this way to move the Queen
instead and castle on the long side
which would mean action
do you think this is the most likely now
I think if a Regice in the current
position if he captures this Knight then
that's almost certainly going to happen
uh magnus's idea is that yes he's given
up uh kind of hoping for a healthy porn
structure but instead he has opened up a
line towards the white king So if
opposite
side castling happens then at least he
has a head start in any attack
really again it's that word provocative
right and he does it he plays it every
guys he's not afraid uh he's standing
his ground this is the most principled
move maybe it's even the best move and
ivanka's idea on the board
and yeah basically he's saying to Magnus
I don't trust you I'm going to go for
these pawns long term they are very very
weak and that's the right approach
against Magnus you know you just gotta
say I don't trust you
um the the has the proof is in the
pudding as we say we have a lot of
strange expressions in English I'm so
I'm sorry to our viewers
and yeah the queen steps forward she
gets ready to perhaps defend the poor
that now come under Fire I mean this
means it's going to be a crazy start to
the quarterfinals right King is on
opposite sides of the horns yeah exactly
and uh I think every game we've seen
between these two even last month even
in the prelims this month when Magnus
said black it's nearly always opposite
so castling or at least one side castles
on the queen side and that just always
naturally leads to these really
unbalanced games and it's already
imbalanced
is taking some big risks so we have you
know chessable courses on everything you
know all kinds of openings and middle
game and end game are there people who
are experts on costling and costling
either this side or this side and
opposite sides or not at all
it's a strategy sometimes you forget to
Castle but you keep your opponent
guessing maybe that's what Magnus is
trying to do now hang on a second I was
looking at some of the games in the
caracon and I was looking at David's
games you do this a lot in the caracon
it doesn't castle and then he just Waits
with his King and then when you least
expect it he moves yeah it's like a
staring contest it's like I'm staring
and then I'm gonna pretend I'm going one
way and you actually as soon as you look
away I'll run the other way but yeah
that's the strategy in chess it's very
risky you've got to kind of attain a
certain level before you can get away
with it because if Magnus leaves it too
long it could backfire the black king
could come yeah could come under a
heavier attack butts I think we're going
to see it now yeah there we go there we
go on the board and uh well action has
been initiated
and uh Eric Garcia has gone for the plan
of perhaps controlling the the central
line
yeah I kind of like this I think this is
a good approach I don't think he should
be going over eager on the left side of
the board pushing up horns instead piece
play
yeah and I really don't understand what
Magnus is doing to be honest because
this Pawn push
I mean in general we love it when Harry
the H porn has pushed up the board
towards the opponent's king but it's a
Lone Ranger this black pawn alone is not
going to do any damage against White's
really nice Pawn structure in front of
his King there also in any end game that
black H Pawn is going to be weak it's
got no buddies around it it's an
isolated Pawn it's an easy target for
White's bishop and White's Knight
yeah I mean long term it's horrible for
black Magnus is playing for dynamic
chances now but I wouldn't be surprised
exactly if ever got a C just says okay
I'm fixing your weakness and now he can
kind of bully Magnus with the thought of
trading off pieces because that black
pawn structure is just so bad
and okay Magnus meanwhile improving one
of his Bishops at least so black he does
have Dynamic play in terms of open lines
and he's got the bishop pair often we
say the bishop pair is worth a pawn in
uh if the center is
kind of uh open out there but at the
moment it's still a bit blocked so white
knight is doing very well
I really as
we did in a fantastic Square I mean it's
really just coordinating just
coordinating uncoordinating black surf
forces I mean I just don't see Magnus
even dreaming about an attack and a
great play by Eric icy yeah still some
big decisions ahead but uh maybe we can
explain as well why white tonight is so
strong and why black won't just take it
off the board for example if white
weights I'm expecting because this
tension is quite unpleasant I'm
expecting at some point white to step
the pawn forward move the king forward
off that diagonal but uh the White
Knight can never really be captured for
example here if Black's King moves the
white king moves both to slave squares
then despite the fact it's opposite
color Bishops white is almost winning
strategically again because these pawns
are just easy targets for the White
Queen and even if you defend those pawns
white can just step back and weaknesses
everywhere this Pawn is just dropping
off the wood it's on a light Square he's
fixed it the isolated pawn and that's
what you want to do strategically fix
your opponent's weaknesses and this Pawn
is never ever going anywhere ideally you
want to kind of Step it a square back
but pawns don't move backwards
unfortunately and looking very good long
term for white so Magnus needs something
now he did choose to move that pawn two
squares forwards so why didn't he just
move one yeah that's a very good
question Kaya um I think if we just
backtrack rewind a couple of moves I'm
not sure he even needs to move it one
square because here the Knight would uh
attack it maybe just leave it here as
long as possible because then it's
harder to attack for white only the
White Queen can ever attack the pawn if
it sits on the Square whereas on the
Square it moved to after erigashi fixed
it now it's easy to attack for for
example long term by the White Knight or
later the white Bishop can attack it so
um yeah I'm just nitpicking here it's a
tiny little detail but it might be
relevant for the rest of the game there
we go see now thinking for over two
minutes but the bar is definitely over
to his side would you be confident if
you were playing this with the white
pieces now
I mean I'd be as confident as I could be
I guess
um yeah I mean I think the opening's
been a success for everybody what about
you yeah I agree I I think it's it's a
great position for Eric I see the only
thing he has to do he has to be careful
about his King he has to
basically be aware of Black's dark
squared bishop and just take the
necessary precautions if you can control
that piece and you can control the Rooks
as well in terms of like making sure
that there's no sacrifices anything to
blast open the position then white is in
full control and uh meanwhile I saw some
answers to our caption this Con
competition you guys are so creative I
quite like Kev zero 007's answer he says
wow these extra strong mints are a lot
bigger than I remember
do we have a winner already no no
that's a good one that is a very good
one that's my humor very nice Kim Kev
was it yeah 007 yeah keep them coming
this picture of Duda with an air things
device we want you to caption this
picture using the hashtag chess Champs
and meanwhile a poem push from Eric I
see again I'm slightly surprised that
both sides form pushes to be honest
they're both taking risks strategically
White's put all his pawns on the left
side on light squares that means he has
no control over the dark squares and
black just happens to have an
uncontested Dark Soul Bishop so slightly
surprising I thought he'd try and put
pawns on Dart squares on that side of
the board every guy so you normally you
want to put pawns on the opposite color
to your own Bishop but uh okay no harm
at the moment and Magnus just playing a
move you should always go for when we
Castle queenside uh move the black king
one square closer to Safety in the
corner and Ivanka what about this one
yeah that one took me by surprise I mean
I thought the bishop would step back and
you know we would see aragaisy off a
trade of works I did not expect this
because uh our guys is like voluntarily
saying to Magnus hey why don't you
[ __ ] my Pawn structure and Magnus
just says well actually I'm not going to
get distracted by those type of things
I'm going to go straight from an attack
towards your king
and uh any attack still needs a few
moves to I mean set things up
essentially but you're right Ivanka I'm
surprised Magnus just avoided this or
just dodged the questions so quickly in
the previous position okay we do see a
Regency move as king now black could
definitely have considered taking this
bishop off the board and whose Pawn
structure is worse now I don't know
these are double pawns blockaded by a
nice Knight on an outpost but these are
also very weak pawns here
um these three isolated doubled for
example The Black Queen at some point
can start coming over and start kind of
eyeing up these pawns eyeing up this
Pawn
I'm very surprised Magnus just ignored
this possibility but maybe he's playing
on the clock situation he's got uh three
minutes more than our Regice but also is
that starting to Young player chess just
making it strategically difficult he
moves his Rook Eric I see reacted quite
quickly by moving his King very sensible
the king is actually on the same file as
a rook it's on the same diagonal as a
bishop so why not just park it on a
safer Square it's closer to the center
which is a bit vulnerable but in general
a better Square than it stood on and
same question do you take this bishop
off the board
eventually you might run out of other
ideas
yeah it kind of feels like because
Magnus didn't do it on the last go that
he's not going to do it now he's going
to let that question linger in the air
for a while and maybe he just improve
the queen
great where would you improve into this
Square maybe this Square yeah I was
thinking all the way to the A5 but
I mean I I am actually at a loss for a
plan for black yeah I guess this is this
kind of standoff with the two Bishops
it's like you take me no please you take
me after you the polite Bishops again
yeah oh that's a really good term for
the polite Bishops neither one wants to
take the other one
um no you hang up first
this is such a British thing as well yes
it is when I was in Austria
there was a security checks and there
was an Austrian there who was like no
mobile phone's good good go come just go
in and then there was a Brit who was
doing the security checks and he was
like mobile phones no mobile phones all
incredibly good
if you could step over here please it's
much nicer
polite Brits I like it
yeah and black doesn't want to take the
white Bishop because then White's Knight
will forever be sitting on an outpost
and vice versa if white takes the black
Bishop then a pawn will recapture
kicking White's Knight away from an
outpost so it's all about keeping that
white knight where it is and that's why
the Bishops are so polite to each other
just
and I mean could we see a scenario where
both sides just kind of play Waiting
moves waiting moves uh just daring the
opponent testing the opponent's patience
the problem is it's easy to improve
White's position you can imagine White's
rook in the center just stepping up one
square or maybe two squares and then the
other rook in the corner sliding across
doubling up the two white Rooks on the
open D file but blackstrokes what are
they doing one of them in the corner the
black rook in the far corner is tied
down defending that black H Pawn that we
talked about
tied down for the rest of the game
essentially so Magnus is playing without
a piece
and thinking now for over three minutes
he has ticked under seven minutes now
Magnus Carlsen the bar is slightly over
to erigga's side in a tense game because
we do see a lot of pieces in the middle
there yeah very tense at the moment we
mentioned the opening went in arugice's
favor but he still has a huge amount of
difficult questions to answer and it's
not clear who wants to simplify things
Eric I see when he's won most of his
games this tournament if we remember
yesterday when he knocked out anishigiri
it was just so complicated pieces all
over the board I think it favors
aragaisy maybe if it's really really
complicated and messy and calculation to
be done Magnus doesn't mind pieces on
the board as long as it's kind of a
slower strategic game
and games we saw the ancient stats
earlier they will favor Magnus so yeah
it's just uh it's just what comes next
that's the big question
yeah it's a bit of a mystery right I am
also wondering whether Magnus will
resort to very Extreme Measures so he
goes forward with his Rook there was a
concrete threat of attacking the queen
so aragaisi immediately pushes the pawn
and controls the F4 Square
and the kind of radical move that I was
thinking and please don't laugh at me
David it was I went and it's really bad
I mean it goes against it goes against
the rules of Chess basically you should
say you should never push pawns on the
side your weakest yeah I was thinking
can you attack that bishop and just
try to you're tired of the the stair
office Ivanka you really want to force
this bishop yeah so rude that's not
polite I know I know it's not polite but
I mean it was an idea and maybe it's
kind of more of a concept actually I
wasn't thinking necessarily this is the
right time but
just something so that you can push
white back a bit yeah I agree as well it
was on my radar maybe more before this
Rook landed on this Square because now a
white Bishop as we mentioned it
definitely doesn't want to take the
black Bishop because now Black's Pawn
structure is still bad but at least you
kick this Knight out of its dream home
on F5 and uh so I therefore I think Eric
icy would answer this with just dropping
back
and the reason I think it's less
attractive now is because when the White
Queen moves The Rook will be hit you
lose a bit of time
I agree um I think Magnus at some point
might get itchy fingers and he might be
tempted to just push this Pawn forward
because the tension is just almost
unbearable wow look at the evaluation
bar there reacting after the offer of a
rook Exchange
by Magnus the problem is
white can just control the open file now
if he wants first move that comes to
mind at least is a rook exchange and now
the other white Rook which was
previously dormant asleep doing nothing
you can bring it across gain time
against the black queen and you control
the open file when she moves
still complicated you still have to
evaluate this type of Pawn structure
that we mentioned earlier for example
The Black Queen coming to attack this
isolated Pawn these two are targets as
well but it does feel like Black's Rook
is a bit clumsy it can get hit by the
White Knight at any point could get
kicked back
it's really heating up despite what the
evaluation Bar says it's for a human at
least uh quite difficult to comprehend
and it's not immediately winning for
white it's maybe a long-term advantage
that he has to nurture very carefully
Eric I see what about you Banker do you
see anything better maybe than yeah I'm
trying to train myself to look at the
forcing moves so actually I was
considering I really liked your work
text work but then I was thinking about
the idea of throwing in Bishop takes
Bishop I know I know we were saying that
this is not good it kind of corrects
Black's Pawn structure but then you do
have some attacks where you can come and
attack the rook and then you're
threatening to come in and uh
take some more take some fun I'm such a
materialist yeah why not if the black
moves you can consider at some point
either before or after a rook exchange
taking this one
this one requires calculation but it's
definitely on the on the radar maybe
that's what I Regice is calculating
right now so this is the current
position he's most likely to play a rook
takes Rook or maybe even trade off the
Bishops at some point watch out for this
idea of going with his Knight to attack
The Rook okay he doesn't he's a man who
likes his tension all right guys he
pushes a pawn forward that is aimed
against your idea of anchor of pushing a
pawn in front of the black king so he's
just saying okay I'm gonna put all my
pretty much all my pieces all my pawns
all on light squares every whoops oh
sorry that was a slip but yeah
everything on light squares basically
because black has a dark Squad bishop
and black start scored Bishop will be
hitting nothing
he's playing checkers but in reverse
yeah really tense
sensible it seems to be a little bit The
Calm before the storm in all the
quarter-final match as well this one the
bar is definitely over to our guys's
side but in the other ones the bars are
roughly in the middle and all the other
game ones in those quarter-final matches
but we know there definitely will be
drama in all of them they will all be
decided today if not in the four rapid
games then end Blitz or Armageddon tie
breaks
come before the storm but this one is
the storm already coming yeah the storm
is brewing and again it's just up to
Eric icy to pull the trigger at some
point and maybe exchange Rooks like we
should and bring the other white Rook
into the game or maybe he just continues
to wait but uh either way the computer
loves his position that means that maybe
there's something immediate
I'm really hating what magnus's Rook
though is just doing on that G4 Square
normally we like putting pieces in the
opponent's half of the board it's
annoying for the opponent but blacks
Rook over there on the right okay he
swaps yeah set of pieces but that black
Rook is just trapped it's just on a bad
Square in fact there was a very good
idea that the computer indicated and it
was just about grabbing material so
something along the lines you showed you
might not going to attack that black
Rook but uh okay what he's done is very
human at least I
I mean it makes much more sense because
computers can navigate all these
unworldly complications but for humans
it's more about control and uh look at
erag I see
completely dominating the position I
mean Magnus is just floundering you know
trying to find an idea and it's not easy
yeah everything on light squares Magnus
is kind of playing one-dimensional chess
he has to find something
some active squares with this queen it's
not
I don't really see it at the moment and
yeah again you can trade Bishops but do
you really want to once you trade off
your Bishop pair you have no uh
influence on the light squares
you're black yeah and also white now has
the only open file in the position the D
file once the black queen runs away
yeah I mean where would you put the
queen I mean I think I would probably
line her up with dark squared Bishop
yeah
bring her somewhere on this left side of
the board but where it's it's not clear
exactly what she's gonna be doing
um
and uh okay three minutes for Magnus
four minutes for Eric I see it could it
could be decided in a Time scramble this
one could turn around if I regrets he
loses control that's the hardest thing
in chess keeping control forever you
nearly never see a game where from move
one to a move 40 50 it's complete
control normally there's one slip or or
as soon as your opponent gets back in or
starts to scare you you kind of freak
out and the momentum changes yeah and at
least from my experience yeah definitely
I mean just to kind of elaborate
normally like one side is like a full
control and then the opponent just makes
one slight break for freedom and the
other person panics yeah it happened to
me a lot sometimes
it's the one inevitable thing in chess
is that we all
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
exchange the queen comes out yeah have
you ever had that David where you've uh
you've just forgotten about the clock
and suddenly you realize you've got like
two seconds left and you have to make a
move when you just bash the clock The
Story of My Life
Simon always says uh he sees me like oh
David's so calm playing with one second
and then pressing the clock is no it's
just panic I just look at it I'm like oh
one second
it's just become second nature
yeah I must admit it is quite a
satisfying in chess you know just to
watch people panic I mean you feel for
them yeah I mean but at the same time
you're kind of thinking I'm so glad it's
not me yeah like um a few people have
some towels
um like someone I know I'm very close to
you my husband does this
panicking he's like oh no oh sorry sorry
Anna I love to play poker against him
no he's quite good at poker actually but
just in chess you know there's there's
remaining when the clock starts sticking
down you know because we don't have that
in poker actually you don't have a clock
in poker yeah you don't have anyone go
move yeah
yeah I guess that's true can you sit
there and have a think for a long time
in poker yeah I think
I mean we miss Lawrence now the poker
expert but I think you can sit there for
a while it's probably Bad Manners to sit
there for like 15 minutes and think like
you're doing chess sometimes but
um okay the white king moving safer
Square okay we have some poker experts
in the control room
I think if someone says time then sort
of a clock-ish starts ticking you have a
time limit you need to make your bet or
yeah it's rare to see I think for more
than a few minutes yeah but okay Black's
Queen is coming in attacking some of
those weaknesses Magnus looking for
counter play this is the type of thing
Magnus he's just trying to scare Eric
icy I don't think it's necessarily a
good move but it's at least forcing
aragaisy to
worry about those white pawns on the
left side yeah well he how is he going
to defend them that is not a easy
question I mean I probably would go on a
counter attack myself and he does attack
The Rook make it move back yeah Black's
Rook needs to move simply I'm not sure
where it goes maybe to sit next to the
White Knight to attack that white knight
but the knights attacking some pawns
White's Queens also attacking those
double Pawns
those black F pawns to be honest I just
want to get rid of them they're just so
ugly oh actually and I like the more I
look at this position the more I really
don't like magnus's position because the
White Knight is gonna grab the F7 Pawn
from there we'll jump forward towards
the center and before you know it it's
looking at the black king
yep just two or three jumps attacking
The Rook first you grab a pawn for
example if Magnus does the same then as
you say Ivanka you might even jump this
way and uh combined with the Rook coming
in you're going for the black king
okay we don't see that on the board
because Magnus was terrified of letting
that knight jump further so he actually
covered this square but now
okay I was gonna say is eragisi going to
get greedy and grab this Pawn this would
have got complicated after the black
Rook moves to attack the White Queen and
Knight at the same time maybe this
double attack was too scary to deal with
so he plays positional chess I like it
Eric I see bringing the queen over
plugging all the holes and again
earlier we saw the polite Bishops now
it's the polite Queens it's like no
please you take me first and uh if
Magnus takes every glyces Queen then
suddenly the white pawns are healthy
again and connected once more so you
definitely don't want to trade Queens if
you're Magnus and uh okay the standoff
continues he moves this Rook to kick
away the White Knight
but now I mean you can Retreat it back
to a great Square
I mean you could even get greedy and go
that way I mean if you want to keep full
control yeah yeah and I like this one
this is the one that I'm first drawn to
do you think Magnus has missed this one
because it looks like it wins a pawn and
the bar now says it it looks like it's
winning for a guy see it's weird because
uh this position it's normally you would
put it on an outpost it's really nice
and anchored here but you're basically
putting your knight on a square where
Black's night started the game oh look
at Magnus and he's realized But Eric I
see does he have the camera open
let's go back to Magnus uh on the camera
now because
I think he's realized that he's
blundered he's missed this night move
that you spotted Ivanka it wasn't on my
my radar I've got to admit okay you
treat me he trades Queen and now he's
gonna do it
okay where's he gonna put his Knight if
he comes back
maybe some chances for Magnus yeah but
he's gonna go forward he's and he's gone
for it and uh that's it Magnus is gonna
go up on down yeah and it's not just any
pawn once that pawn Falls but the white
Knight's gonna gobble up the rest of his
position is going to collapse
wow yeah Black's night starts the game
on this Square what's he doing
yeah really nice move from aragosi it's
easy to miss the type of move right
normally you think oh I've got my back
ranks protected but
this one that's what I think sometimes I
just forget when the opponent can jump
right into the heart of my hand and this
is kind of one of those ironies right
it's super easy for the defender to miss
the type of move but it's actually very
easy for the attacker to see it the legs
forward
but uh yeah
yeah and the White's Rook is also going
to dive into the seventh row I mean it's
just uh
getting worse and worse
Magnus I mean it was just that decision
to allow those double pawns I think it's
backfired long-term error guys he kept
control so well there will still be a
couple of moments where he has to show
good composure to win this one but he's
done it perfectly so far yeah and is
there any I was going to say that is
there any hope based on this active King
go Rogue go home
I mean I guess the Rook can come up to
the seventh row and just put a stop to
the king marching yeah happily forward
and it does
White's Rook dominates I mean it
controls everything it's in seventh
heaven as we say on the seventh rank
and uh it's just got so many targets I
think this is magnus's final hope to get
active with his King munch on some pawns
actually blacks he's banking everything
on the black a pawn so he's gonna get
rid of the pawn next to that black king
right now and then he's gonna throw his
April forward and
hope that uh while the rest of position
rest of his position crashes and burns
that he's quick enough
first you need to push push the black
apple and then you need to get the black
king out the way not easy
it's going to take a while it's going to
take a long time white tonight can just
get greedy now and it should
another Rook steps forward
[Laughter]
two points up now or he will be in a
moment Eric I see one Pawn
and Counting
yeah I mean it's not so easy for
aragaiti to establish his own past Pawn
despite being quite a bit material up
yeah so he has uh Magnus has that hope I
mean when you're defending this type of
position just go as active as you can
just rely on those slim chances because
hope is that the Harry Potter quote
quote is like that little flicker of
light and darkness beautiful
I don't know where they said that
exactly but it sounded it sounded about
right have you ever seen Ted lasso the
TV show uh you mentioned it once yeah
that's the final episode of the first
season the title is It's the hope that
kills you oh and it's the same in chess
it's like you get your hope up and then
it all falls apart anyway and then it's
like ah why did I even get why didn't he
even get optimistic
very brutal
and lasso is that the football coach
yeah yeah Jason Sudeikis yeah
yeah on that subject apparently hope is
the big relationship killer as well ah
yeah
so yeah maybe don't hope unless you're
defending a getting a position
for Magnus in this position
maybe not after this move this is a
really sneaky one by Eric icy it's just
so impressive these young Indian players
they are always on the lookout for
tactics even when they've got a
strategic Advantage most of us would be
thinking okay let's grab some pawns
let's round things up but does this win
a piece Ivanka
how is Black's Bishop going to survive
okay it does move but now Black's King
is completely trapped he's got to be
careful not to get checkmated Magnus uh
let's just show why that pawn wasn't
edible why you couldn't capture this
Pawn Eric icy here rather than the move
I was thinking take a pawn for free uh
he threw this Pawn forward setting a
trap the bishop has not many safe
squares if it takes this Pawn this would
be a check the King has to move and a
second check and King has to move again
and you gobble up the bishop you win a
piece so Magnus is only safe Square I
mean this is such a clever tactic the
only safe Square for this bishop is this
one the black can hardly move and I'm
wondering whether the white king can go
and trap the black king I mean it is it
you want to just dance over here I mean
it's a journey but you know why not and
uh okay he's pushing forward with his
Pawn yep I like this plan your vanco
just move the king for example let's
just say black weights for the next few
moves you're using the white king to
take away Black's only Escape square and
uh here this would be Checkmate really
really nice but everybody didn't go for
this one he did instead something
similar I guess he just pushed the pawn
forward just to lock in this black
Bishop
and where's this bishop going is this
just no safe squares look at what Magnus
has done yeah go back my friend yeah
he's moved his bishop and now he has to
go back
but actually wait let's check me again
it's magnus's Bishop gone yeah that's it
he has to give up his bishop and uh it
will be game over our guys he's about to
win now he can just take this bishop
the only small trap is after the bishop
is captured the black king will move
White's Rook moves and the pawn starts
running but I think you can easily come
back and stop this Pawn with your knight
he doesn't even grab it Eric I see this
really classy he doesn't want to allow
the black king
onto the b-file he's still cutting it
off first he gets greedy and the Knight
is coming back he's still going to win
the bishop with a simple Knight check
that's gonna be the end of the game
any moment now Magnus is gonna resign
oh what a start to this quarter final
match Eric icy about to win his second
game in a row against the world champion
incredible
wow actually that was a trap that Magnus
was setting uh but a Regice he didn't
fall for it if the white knight had come
back and taken the black Bishop what
Black's king would have come in just
like it's doing in the game
the problem is now you are three pawns
down
as Magnus
and everybody just needs to move his
Rook to a safe Square yeah still
completely winning just don't put it on
the E1 Square that's the only Square I
would say just
he puts it on that square yeah and
Magnus frowns yeah that was the one
square I was like No just don't do it
because the bishop takes Pawn but uh
there we sing it uh guys who's worked it
out that you can give a check but the
black king will take a step down and
attack okay steps forward but now the
Rook can just lift itself up and give
another check yeah
through it can also go and defend its
Knight perhaps but a check is easiest as
you mentioned still two pawns up for
aragaisy maybe I rooted off too soon
maybe Magnus is fighting he's still
completely losing but the longer the
game goes on the more frustrated Eric
Garcia might become rook and Bishop do
work better than Rooker Knight that's
one thing I've learned from you Ivanka
um the night now defending its pawn and
Magnus does have an active King as well
so there's still some fighting chances
left
not looking good but there's hope
there's a glimmer a tiny little bit of
Hope here
are a guy see he still needs to win it
winning positions are the hardest ones
to finish off in chess I'm expecting at
some point the White Knight to come back
into the game but first there we go see
goes after Black's F Pawn Yeah that's
the problem for Magnus his three pawns
are all isolated the black Pawns
and that black rock is pretty terrible
and it still is yeah there's uh no way
it's getting into the game
um
it is an end game though magnus's
strength usually and or a guy she just
moves his Rook forward defending
everything
a Magnus attacking The Rook causing it
to dislodge so he's one back of Pawn ah
is Eric icy struggling to find the
killer blow in this game
it feels like it the evaluation bar
thinks he's still completely in control
but he was three pawns up just a few
moves ago then it disappeared then it
became two now it's only one Pawn so
the momentums in magnus's favor unless
aragaisy can find a killer blow and this
might be the Killer
again it's that night going to the top
of the board and it's easy to see for an
attacker from this point of view but
maybe for Magnus not so easy the black
pawns are just dropping like flies
and uh
the same Knight takes porn yeah
why it's night can get greedy it looks
pretty safe
it looks like we can have another
decided game here in the first round of
the quarterfinals Mama Yara the bar just
shut up for him with the black pieces in
game one against obdisator of
on it's back to people an advantage for
Eric icy
and uh Magnus he is such a Wily
character you know he knows how to make
an opponent's life difficult because I
mean yes I Regice he has all these pawns
extra but it's difficult to advance them
and the pawn on C5 is dropping
so still some risk in the position for
Eric is it's not as clean as he would
have liked it to be yeah especially not
with 30 seconds left on the clock and
actually this is the second time we've
seen this position now so they have
repeated this position once and regards
he has to find something else if he
wants to win the game he brings his King
forward
very sensible however there is a pin so
white tonight is pinned it can't move
because of the tension on the f file
between the Rooks
okay I was going to say it's hard to
find a useful move anyway but he's going
back with his Bishop he's threatening to
attack that Knight with the black bishop
and that's why every guys he pushes
forward because now the king protects
White's Rook
the problem is things are disappearing
he wants to win Black's remaining Pawn
he didn't want to swap it off
so there's
again this tiny bit of Hope if black can
give up his Bishop for all of White's
remaining Pawns
it's asking a lot though that is asking
a lot from the position and he steps up
with his Rook an hour this case of just
pushing your pawns forward
come in with the white king as yeah go
attack that black Bishop I like your
plan
okay he does push one of the pawns
forward onto a light Square
maybe just to guard some squares against
the black king
[Music]
I'm getting ready to maybe Retreat the
White Knight White's main weakness is
the sea pawn and white C Pawn can be
defended by his Knight on the next move
okay Magnus I've got to say Magnus has
played better maybe since he went into a
losing end game than he did in the
earlier phase of the game he's made it
really difficult for Eric icy but I have
to say I've been very impressed by Eric
icy I mean the way he's handled this
position he hasn't really given Magnus a
chance yeah he might have taken the long
route but still the result has never
been in doubt yeah
not yet
and uh it's just about whether he can
finish it off so he basically needs to
get one of those white Pawns marching
forwards which one is his best bet
it's hard to say I think he wants to
keep them all intact uh so one Pawn
might distract the black Army and then
you just you kind of use it as a
distraction then you go with another
Pawn but he's defending everything right
now
uh apart from this one but now the other
black porn drops so it's two pawns
versus zero and actually if Black's King
was all the way maybe at the top of the
board in front of the white pawns
there's some serious drawing chances but
the black king is so far away
and it feels like White's pawns
eventually will be able to race
too fast for the black for the black
king to keep up
so uh still winning but still some work
to be done okay definitely Magnus is of
course Very used to being the one on
sort of the white side of this kind of
position grinding it out getting those
two pawns over there how used to see is
he to defending this
he's not used to it at all Magnus very
rarely enters any end games where he's
dead lost uh like this one
and I think we're about to see it Kyle
White's pawns are going to step forward
okay I mean you can choose either of
them right now
to March forward white normally you want
to kind of do them push them in unison
so fourth rank then Fifth Fifth Sixth
sixth but okay white each point is very
close the big threat on the board The
Rook is threatening to give a check to
the king and aragaisy of course sees
that and uh protects his Knight
yeah and this is why Black's King is on
the wrong side of the board because
Black's King does not play any role
whatsoever in stopping the white pawns
and now the age Pawn is just going to
push to the sixth row
here looks good enough Black's idea
though is to keep attacking both pawns
black will maybe go after the pawn next
to the white king in a moment
still not 100 easy when in doubt maybe
just give a check with the white Rook
just gain a bit of time on the clock for
a guy see
they look like a really good a good team
those white pieces yeah all just
protecting each other just following
each other off the board that's what we
call coordination in chess when they're
all within the same they're all
controlling the same area they're all
protecting each other okay Magnus
frowning that yeah this is a very
natural trick where does he go with the
black king you don't really want to go
to the left you don't want to go away
from the action
but the problem is if you don't go away
you have to go down the board also
further from the action further from the
white Pawns
and the one thing that everybody has to
avoid he cannot let black give up his
Bishop for White's two remaining pawns
because rook and Knight can't beat a
rook on their own that's a drawn end
game okay so that's magnus's one trick
if he can somehow give up his Bishop for
both of the white pawns you can give up
the bishop for one but you have to get
rid of both of the pawns get rid of both
of the potential Quints okay
Magnus he has stacked up a lot of time
on the clock so he does have time now to
think about as a strategy to save this
game but it's not looking good and Eric
icy seems so confident so calm oh it's
that typical we talked yesterday about
body language right every player has a
certain pose mine is like normally like
this but Eric I see it's just always
with a hand on his head just never never
flinches
and okay the game goes further away
black is now surely going to attack
White's F Pawn next to the white king
yeah has to step up three squares and
there we go it's attacked now how is he
gonna defend this Pawn Yeah it's not
easy at all actually to defend both of
your Pawns
the problem is if you defend this Pawn
with the white knight you get in the way
of The Rook Maybe
do you have to give up one of your Pawns
but if you only have one Pawn remaining
suddenly the winning chances might
disappear
Magnus fighting like a lion he's got to
be said
I can't believe I wrote him off what was
it 20 30 moves ago I I thought the game
would have ended a long time ago to be
honest with you but uh Magnus he's
keeping the game alive and uh yeah
aragaisi has given up one of his pawns
okay he's banking everything on the H
Pawn
it still feels winning but this is the
type of position the evaluation bar
I'm so confused it should say either
plus 10 or it should say zero the fact
that it's kind of plus three means it's
probably winning but you don't think
it's looking at a position where black
has given up the bishop
I'm not sure Ivanka it's really uh hard
to say okay black Bishop took a pawn
and now it's all about White's H porn so
white needs to win the black Rook for
his Pawn he doesn't want to allow the
bishop to get back onto the long
diagonal and stop that pawn advancing
is Magnuson time okay so I've pulled up
the table base and it says it's losing
okay but okay it needs to catch up with
the current position
okay so objectively everybody is still
winning
but now the margin for error is smaller
he was completely winning the whole well
most of the game now but Eric I see and
he had a you know he could let a pawn go
and he's still winning but he could no
longer
allow Magnus to fight back but so iffy
Queens
and the BlackRock takes the queen
but the the work is in time to take the
black Rook then it's winning so he wants
to give up his uh black wants to give up
The Bishop's life for the white party he
doesn't want to give up the rook's life
for the white Point yeah so the winning
kind of idea is that the white king
should come forward help support its uh
pawn and uh yeah
so in this position support the he plays
it yeah we go see so you support your
Pawn you freed up the white Rook the
next move if you want to use your Rook
to go up one square maybe and promote
this Pawn what happens I guess it's just
difficult for the black Bishop to ever
land on this diagonal the problem is if
you ever land here then the White Knight
is going to come back and these types of
tactics where there's going to be kind
of double attacks and forks that's maybe
going to prevent black from getting his
dream set up
Bishop needs to somehow get to this long
diagonal if it can it's a draw but he
can't do it safely that's why he moves
this Rook now for example if the white
knight steps forward I guess his idea is
to use his Bishop
Bishop will sacrifice its life
not The Rook okay so that's why
everybody steps back with his Knight to
stop the bishop using this Square yep
you do have a result it's a win for mama
diara with a black pieces in game one
against Abdu satorov a long game ending
up with a win for Mama diarov and just
looking on chess 24 it looks like
abdicator of lost uh just went down to
zero on the clock I don't know but it
looked like he was losing on the board
as well
yeah and they're talking about losing on
the board uh all error guys he has to do
is actually step forward with his rook
and support the promotion of the pawn it
was winning immediately that wasn't
winning immediately yeah instead he
gives a check it's okay though you can
still lost
can he do it now bring his Rook up one
square White's Rook if it goes to the
eighth rank will support the promotion
there we go of the white Pawn
I'm struggling to see what black can try
okay he goes for the Black Knight for
the White Knight sorry yeah and again
Magnus setting all the tricks it's not
possible to promote the pawn because uh
there will be a whole load of captures
And Trades I look at Magnus he's put his
Bishop as far away from the White Knight
as possible
now is it drive this move is now a draw
wow it's a night move the Knight moving
to the G4 I'm just checking the table
bases here and it's saying now it's a
draw that night move was a mistake he's
a loud blacks Bishop onto its dream
diagonal no no how can you ever
how can you ever win the black Rook for
the pawn how can you ever block the
black Bishop
it's got this perfect long diagonal
it actually makes sense that it's a
drawn out unless every guy so you can
somehow land a night fork or land a
trick a double attack
where was the windy of anchor it must
have been just a few moves ago
and uh Eric icy now has to do it all
over again he has to win it from square
one yep whoa
yeah so uh
okay the moves are coming fast
but uh yeah he did Mr Elementary win
that we kind of pointed out but there
was it was the night moving to the G4
square that was a critical mistake there
was only one chance to save it
yeah and uh
now that black Bishop is perfectly
parked
and Black's Rook is just doing such a
good job of harassing from behind and
maybe we can just show the win uh while
uh while the players are now battling it
out this one is going to go on for a
long time but in this position he blew
it he blew the uh the victory now Eric I
said by stepping away with this Knight
allowing the black Bishop onto this long
diagonal and now the game's gonna go on
a long time but for example there were
tricks for example moving the Knight
forward uh threatening to promote to a
new Queen if the black Bishop steps onto
this diagonal now you can simply I think
remove the
I'm not 100 sure actually remove the
bishop and then block and try to make a
new Queen but uh back in the game
situation and Regice he's trying a
similar idea the Knight is blocking the
Rook but how do you block this bishop
you can't you can't you think it's a
draw now your anchor it says um hang on
let's go
draw
as long as this this bishop stays on
this diagonal it's gonna be a draw
nothing for it yeah for example just to
to highlight once more
um this end game even if you make a new
Queen which you might try at some point
if you make a new Queen win Black's
Bishop Rook a knight against a rook is a
draw
will take some work but he'll hold this
easily magnusly I don't think he would
ever lose professor's Rook at night how
impressive is that that was completely
losing totally lost
and uh wow Magnus showing us all why
he's such an angry game Maestro you know
and also defend them
I had written him off and he was two
pawns down Eric Garcia had the control
and it looked like he was completely
outclassing the world champion
[Music]
yeah I mean he's he's just miraculous
yeah and uh his aim chess
resourcefulness stats are gonna shoot
off the charts now Magnus oh yeah but
arag I see the advantage capitalization
lacking there today lacking that Killer
Instinct
I mean so if this game finishes in a
draw as we think it will
how do you think Eric guys can come back
from this because this is going to be
heartbreaking and the brain is not going
to let him forget that he he could have
won so in so many ways the brain likes
to do this to you as well yeah yeah he
wouldn't be human if he wasn't just
devastated by this yeah I mean it will
feel like a defeat simply I mean do you
think that he will manage to come back
from this or do you think that's now
Magnus has
a decisive Advantage I was saying the
rest of the match Magnus will have two
whites after the next three games Magnus
will have that massive confidence boost
he'll think that he's got away with
murder Magnus in this game and if he can
survive this uh the world champion then
he he'll think he can survive Anything
Eric I see Sonny will lose confidence in
his uh in his own yeah in his own killer
well his own chances simply in the match
because when you draw this type of
position I mean you think you come out
of it with such a buzz and it feels like
you've almost won
and the King just moves away but it
doesn't doesn't change the situation
that it still draw black has the optimum
defensive setup you know Bishop is on
the perfect square Rook is doing its job
it's all good I'm just looking at it
every single move that black Place
here's a draw yeah unless you blunder
your Rook or Bishop yes in one move you
draw uh you can move the black king draw
you can move the black Rook back to
attack the White Knight draw one more
move though is perhaps natural that it
is a terrible move is actually moving
the bishop to the D4 Square where it's
lined up with a rook that's the only
kind of move I would say that's
Flex Bishop is actually perfect just
very safe this is actually nice
practical play from Carlson just putting
his Bishop far away from ever getting in
to a knife Fork
um Black's King will never really get
checked by the White Knight in the near
future
and okay Magnus he's got one minute
built up a bit of time
they played now for 61 minutes super
long game one in this quarter final
match the other games were also very
long in the first round here in the
coach finals but they have now finished
the games and gukesh Report should be
starting game two very shortly
the other ones should be starting
shortly as well these two will have 15
minute break as soon as this game
finishes before game two starts
when I progress we might be here for a
while as aragosi tries to somehow trick
uh trick Magnus but Black's Bishop is
just
phenomenal Defender suddenly
okay coming back with his King
do you think we'll see a blunder from
Magnus here I mean because the defense
is just involved keeping the bishop on
this diagonal and as long as it doesn't
put itself in any funny position so if
once say for instance same line as the
king or the same line as The Rook should
be fine just uh computer is just saying
just Shuffle it between the A1 and B2
Square
it's hard to argue with that and here we
go Black's Rook is actually going to
annoy white by checking from the side he
tried checking from behind so Black's
Rook was checking the white king
vertically now he's going to check the
king horizontally
first a check from Eric I see but
doesn't help at all the black king can
move to any safe Square
and White's Pawn so close but so far
and there's no way he can use his white
king to you know get rid of that Bishop
to kind of block out that Bishop that's
what he needs to do but unfortunately
this is where the black Rook steps in
every time he tries to set up a
formation just to block that powerful
Bishop The Rook comes harasses the pawn
and he's about to win that white pawn
and we can't even see a scenario where
white wins the black Bishop for that
pawn anymore
it's gone the pawn and we're gonna see a
draw
any moment
what I mean water results uh we thought
it was going to be so different yeah a
narrative would have been a full 360.
and I can tell on social media on
Twitter everyone is like Magnus
I mean it's just an epic comeback I
absolutely agree with that yeah
now if Magnus wants to play it safe
he'll just take White's Pawn even at the
cost of the black Bishop because that
end game is a draw okay we do go into
that he could also have moved his Bishop
but uh this one
we'll get to learn some end game
technique some endgame strategy from
both of them I mean this one is quite a
simple draw I would say especially
compared to rook and Bishop versus Rick
you saw the other day yeah that one yeah
you know you have to know the defensive
resources here it's just a case of just
chucking the white king I mean how how
long will they play this out
I think we'll see our guysi try for at
least 20 moves or so maybe not the full
50.
yeah as you say Ivanka the whole
strategy for black at some point you
will get your king pushed to one of the
edges of the board but you just check
from afar and then pin the White Knight
that's all you need to know and just
don't let the king sit opposite opposite
each other if your king is trapped on
the back rank
so yeah yeah we'll we'll talk you guys
through the points if and when they come
the key defensive strategies
yeah it looks like both players now
they're like
what a game
this 100 moves too many the magnets must
be happy to sort of prove that he can
also
defend yes end games that he usually
right it's it's a kind of a form of
domination over your opponent you know
if they get these winning positions and
they still can't win them against you
and uh there we see a check and this is
definitely an epic defensive try from
Magnus and uh Hadi Ahmad asks both of us
what's our best chess game of all time
uh our personal game or yeah personal
game
ah good question
I get I've been asked this a few times I
can never give a good answer because
none of my games are perfect all right
um okay Magnus just setting a trick here
there's going to be a discovered Jack if
the black king moves next turn
it looked like he was walking into a
night Fork sorry I got uh confused about
that but uh my best game of all time
I'll say how will cover above
from the grand Swiss last year ah
how about you Ivanka it was my game
against uh sassy Kieran at the British
championships in 1999 and it was the
very first time I was playing someone
who was Grandmaster strength I don't
think he was a Grandmaster and I just
thought that I was gonna lose you know
because I was playing with the black
pieces and I ended up playing really
really well I kept surprising him maybe
he played really badly but I thought I
played a fantastic game and I came up
with the most creative idea I've ever
had in my life and I was really nervous
actually about playing it and then when
I did it he just looked at me like what
and I was like but there's a plan
it's always satisfying yeah the computer
hates it these days you know when I
check checked it out the community's
like no what are you doing and I'm like
no no
to check out that game later as well see
if you can spot my move I will and
meanwhile the black king has been pushed
near the edge of the board the problem
is it has taken Eric icy a whole lot of
time yeah and this is the technique for
Magnus now the black king is just going
to run the other way away from the white
king most likely normally you want to
keep your Rook pinning the White Knight
or at least checking the white king here
white tonight can't participate in the
attack anymore because it's pinned so
we'll run the other way with the black
king
67 minutes long this game right now and
only two Rooks two kings and a knight
left on the board and that should not be
enough to win a game this is not enough
I mean as long as the Rook now gives a
check from behind and now this is
David's point the Knight is penned the
king runs away yeah that's soon as the
Knight blocks a check you run the other
way from your opponent's king and Magnus
looking away he's impatient for this one
to finish
and the last capture was on move 102.
so the 50 move rule will come into
effect at move one five two you've still
got a while to go one of the longest
games of the tournament so far yeah
why why are they not agreeing in draw
wise and there's another move repetition
here
Eric guys he's frustrated with himself
so here we were talking about Chess
manage chess etiquette the other day
it's considered a bit rude to offer a
draw if you're defending and can only
hope to get a draw maximum which is
magnus's case here he can never ever win
even if he wins the white Rook for free
he is still a draw Rook versus knight
but for aragaisy there's still some
winning chances if black doesn't know
how to defend so it's up to Eric I see
to offer the draw and we can't blame him
I think it's that fighting spirit that
we admire to keep playing
we don't like premature draw office
we'll learn a bit from this end game
yeah anyway and there we go a pin a
check followed by a pin and Black's King
will never be cornered and I have to say
some some player some Grand Masters have
actually lost this end game I mean
they've been in worse kind of scenarios
like the King has been pushed all the
way to the bottom row I can remember
um Judith lost against Kasparov yeah
Judith Pogo lost this once I think
one of those two lost uh this end game
once as well so very strong players but
usually that's when the king's already
in the corner and there's a couple of
specific tricks here Black's king is not
quite
pushed to the side of the board I
realize he's still trying I think he's
going to go the full 50. I think so too
100 yards because when you're annoyed
with yourself you tend to play this
position out I mean if it were kind of a
natural situation where it was a normal
game where both sides played Fighting
Chess I think we would have seen a draw
but because Eric icy had such a
dominating position
he's not ready to let go of that Victory
maybe it's good strategy for the match
in general for Eric I see he's the
younger player
um also he's getting it out of his
system the longer he plays this one the
more he'll forget that he was completely
winning earlier in the game
how about you Ivanka have you had this
end game before once I was on the
defending side and you I drew I I was
just and this is also finally you draw
both players shaking their heads look at
Eric I see he obviously knows he was
completely winning this game
but now it is a draw the first game and
in 15 minutes Magnus Carlsen will have
the white pieces in game two in their
quarterfinals it was a long and
interesting game and here is today's
Lisa vetta learning